in this video we'll talk about alcohol
addiction
we learn alcohol consumption is good or
bad
we would also learn and look at the
harmful effects of alcoholism
so stay tuned till the end of this video
and this video is dedicated for general
audience not exclusive to med students
or biology students
alcohol addiction is bad even at a
moderate level we have to understand
why so this is the global alcohol
consumption
in the world and you can see in some
places they drink
16 liters of alcohol per person
that's a lot
but have you ever wondered why we prefer
alcohol so much why it is so addictive
what is the cause behind alcohol
addiction
many people say
it reduces their anxiety it makes them
feel good and it calms them down
are these things true well let's find
out
so let's learn what is the biology
behind the alcohol addiction
in order to understand that we have to
understand how alcohol is affecting our
brain
so once alcohol is consumed it leaves
our gastrointestinal system
and it enters the bloodstream
while in the bloodstream it can
circulate throughout the body and can
eventually reach our brain
our brain is protected by the blood
brain barrier and it doesn't allow
anything to get inside but alcohol can
easily makes its way through the
blood-brain barrier and can reach the
brain
now once in the brain alcohol affects
several pathways
one of the major
neurological pathways that
alcohol effect is the dopaminergic
system
there are several dopaminergic pathways
mesocortical pathway
nigrostatal pathway and mesolimbic
pathway
anyway these names are not important but
what is important is this mesolimbic
pathway is important for our reward and
this is responsible for giving us the
feeling of pleasure and euphoria
and alcohol affects this particular
pathway
that kind of explains why we feel good
after drinking alcohol and our brain
wants more alcohol
so this was the basis of alcohol
addiction
alcohol does more to our brain
it affects the nucleus accumbens
amygdala which are both
responsible for giving us that
satisfying feeling after alcohol
consumption
it affects the hippocampus and sometimes
it's affect the memory so when we see
our blackout-like situation after
consumption consumption of alcohol it's
due to that
alcohol can affect medulla oblongata and
cerebellum both of these brain
structures are associated with motor
coordination so obviously there would be
poor motor current coordination and
sluggish reflexes
and in terms of the entire cortex which
process all the higher order behavior
alcohol slows the cortical activity down
that's why we feel drowsy
now the mechanism by which alcohol slows
the activity down is by agonizing the
gaba receptors
so it acts on the gaba receptors and
brings down the activity of overall
neuronal circuits
now that is why we feel dizzy after
alcohol and alcohol is a potent sedative
as well
alcohol comes on some consumption
increases the global alcohol global
cancer burden
so total 4 of the
cancer
diagnosed in 2020 was due to alcohol
consumption people would think if i
consume moderate alcohol it's good
now all the cancers that were attributed
to alcohol consumption 13.9 percent was
due to moderate consumption
so moderate consumers are not really
safe
and
76.7 percent of alcohol attributed to
cancer in men so men are more vulnerable
compared to females
so around 2020
7540
males were affected in
cancer and among them all these cases in
males were due to alcohol
whereas uh one lakh seventy thousand
individual were affected by uh cancer in
females
and it has been seen
heavy drinkers were 56 percent of them
and females were like 18 percent were
heavy drinker
but the risk was also there in moderate
drinker or
people who drink a little bit than
moderate
so alcohol is overall a depressant
it makes everything go slow it reduces
your heart rate it reduces blood
pressure reduces the brain activity
overall it bring down your consciousness
and you feel dizzy
alcohol consumption has a bad toll on
your reproductive health
it reduces your sperm ground
it
changes the morphology of the sperms and
motility of the sperms all of these
reduce the chance
of a successful reproduction
for pregnant women alcohol is super bad
because it can affect the developing
womb and brain development of the baby
it can lead to premature birth and also
it can lead to low weight during the
birth
and sometime the child are born with
autistic behavior
so alcohol consumption is overall bad
and it affects our liver because this is
the tissue which metabolize alcohol
so drinking a large amount of alcohol
even just for few days can change the
liver composition it can allow
deposition of fat into the liver and
this is known as fatty liver disease
and in extreme situation there would be
shirosis of the liver
where a lot of fat has been accumulated
in the liver and liver is significantly
scarred and damaged
so in short there are a lot of
harmful consequences of alcohol
consumption alcohol is addictive
it drags you into this harmful
consequence
so this is the time to say no to alcohol
in order to spread this awareness share
this video with your friends
and your peers
if you want notes and flashcards you can
get in my facebook page or in my
instagram page all the links are
provided in description you can support
my channel by clicking on the super
thanks option which is in the bottom
right corner of the video you can pay
using paytm paypal or beam upi app
anyway all my social media links are
provided in the description you can
check them out anytime soon next video